[Musique]
je ne le seront pas le temps où l'on
jouait au chat et à la souris avec les
voitures a bien changé il existe
maintenant sur le pont jacques cartier
une voie cyclable sécuritaire ouverte à
l'année
je répondais mais pour en arriver là
des militants d granola comme on les
appelait à l'époque ont dû s'organiser
c'était vraiment perçu comme des voyants
dans ce pot sérieux c'était un cétacé
dénigrer même je vous dirais tôt pris au
sérieux
le vélo c'est un jouet en lève toi
dedans russe igor qu'est ce qu'il fait
là j'avais un cas ce que ce feuilleton
casse donc avait 7 ans guérilla
constante une guérilla dont plusieurs
ont joint les rangs selon les chiffres
les plus récents
le québec compte 4,2 millions de
cyclistes soit 600 milles de plus qu'en
deux cyclistes sur trois ans font toutes
les semaines presque deux fois plus
qu'il y à 25 ans et ceux qui l'utilisent
comme moyen de transport occasionnel à
tripler si on se compare aux autres
provinces canadiennes
si on se compare aux etats unis c'est la
province
parmi les provinces état où il ya le
plus de cyclistes une culture cycliste a
implanté la mission de vélo québec
depuis 1967
on investit tous les champs d'action qui
ne permettait pas pu progresser la place
vélo l'organisme est à la fois une
maison d'édition une agence de voyage
une firme d'experts conseils et une
association cycliste je vous dirai quand
on est là dans les deux trois plus
grandes organisations cyclistes de la
planète mais aussi et surtout le tour de
l'île de montréal cette édition l'an 86
dont a mis quinze mille personnes dans
les rues de montréal
et là c'est comme si les gens avaient
réalisé parce que quand vous faites un
événement de masse comme ça c'est comme
une démonstration publique que le vélo
est éminemment populaire et a créé ce
vin tout ce qu'ont proposé ça
fonctionnait assez bien alors en 1995 il
y avait 2000 315 km de voies cyclables
au québec
aujourd'hui on en retrouve plus de 12000
km et pour vélo québec qui dit piste
cyclable dit plus de sécurité dans les
années 60 il y avait environ une
soixantaine de cyclistes qui décèdent
chaque année au québec c'était
principalement des enfants
aujourd'hui on parle en dix et quinze
personnes qui décèdent au québec
on a observé une diminution du nombre
d'accidents d'environ 20% à laval depuis
une dizaine d'années on développe le
réseau cyclable principalement sur les
grands axes routiers en 2014 on avait un
seulement 119 km de voies cyclables donc
chaque année on vient rajouter 1,15 à
1,25 km
l'objectif est d'atteindre 450
kilomètres d'ici 2031 6e quelques
éléments de grains en majorité c'était
très bien accueilli donc moi ça
m'encourage à montréal plusieurs projets
de l'administration de valérie plantes
ne font pas l'unanimité dont le plus
récent le réseau express vélo jusque pas
croire qu'on est rendus là aujourd'hui à
sortir les mêmes arguments visant un
statu quo qui vise à une limitation
développement de la pratique du vélo
comme on sortait ses arguments il ya
vingt cinq ans dans le vélo est là pour
rester hélas pour croire est là pour
revendiquer encore plus de place pour
des raisons d'environnement pour des
raisons de bruit pour des raisons de
pollution pour des raisons de savoir
vivre
la pratique du vélo dépasse les
frontières urbaine la route verte
reconnu internationalement proposait de
1300 km de voies cyclables dans toutes
les régions de la province
900 km de plus sont en développement
elle fête ses 25 ans cette année pour
applique des voies ferrées c'était au
départ qu'un oeil là bas dont du train
c'était un no man's land
c'était une dont des gens allaient jeter
des déchets et c'est devenu un levier
économique fantastique pour des petits
villages des petites villes et avec
l'émergence du vélo électrique
la pratique se développera davantage
déjà mon pouvoir habiter à 10 15 km de
leur lieu de travail leur lieu de
destination et se dire j'y vais à vélo
parce que maintenant j'ai un vélo à
assistance électrique
un changement de garde s'opère à vélo
québec la pandémie a fait disparaître
les deux tiers de ses revenus et de ses
employés vélo québec estime que le
gouvernement devrait investir 100
millions de dollars par année pendant
quelques années pour structurer le
réseau cyclable
le ministère des transports versent en
moyenne 10 millions $ annuellement
selon l'organisme le vélo dans une ville
c'est comme la grenouille dans un marais
plus explicite dans une ville et pied
donc ils vivent bien plus laver les
dents santé plus les animations
d'harmonie
[Applaudissements]